Film Courage: Lee you mentioned earlier planning
and tracking software.
I’m wondering in terms of screenwriting
programs can they really teach someone to
be a better writer?
Lee Jessup: No.
[Laughs].
Truly writing is inspiration.
Writing is a craft.
If you get a hammer, it’s not going to teach
you to be a better carpenter.
It may make the creation of carpentry easier.
It’s not going to teach you how to be a
better writer.
It is a craft.
It is a craft that has to be practiced.
Sure there are tools like Dramatica to help
you, etcetera, etcetera.
And there is SAVE THE CAT and all of those.
But I’ve seen writers take on SAVE THE CAT
and not get screenwriting to save their lives.
It’s not paint by numbers.
And (you know) if you’re color blind, painting
by numbers is really not going to work for
you and that’s pretty much the equation.
So I think that all of those things have their
uses and I think that they can be very important
guides for the mechanics of your work but
you the writer are going to have to master
the craft.
I’m a big believer in Malcolm Gladwell’s
10,000 hours.
You shouldn’t be shy of getting those.
For most writers, the first script is not
going to be ‘The Script.’
The second script is not going to be ‘The
Script.’
You are going to have to really get better
at your craft and there is no short-cutting
that.
Even if you filled out the 40 beats of SAVE
THE CAT perfectly, that does not mean a perfect
script, ever.
Film Courage: Right…let’s take Malcolm
Gladwell’s THE OUTLIERS in terms of environment
and fostering genius or genius already being
in someone but environment either hindering
it or getting it out there Have you seen that?
Lee Jessup: Oh certainly!
Listen there has to be a kernel of genius
there.
You can be a technically proficient writer
but if you’re not able to invest some soul
in your work.
If you’re not able to feel the way that
it sings, then it will always feel mechanical.
I had a girlfriend growing up who really,
really wanted to be a great pianist.
She never felt it.
So her playing was entirely proficient but
entirely cold.
And the same thing happens with screenplays.
There has to be some (whether we want to call
it genius or anything else) talent, something
innate that you’re able to invest in the
work that makes it uniquely your own or else
it just becomes a perfectly, technically executed
screenplay, but not a great screenplay.
And I do believe that is the difference between
good and great, that extra thing.
And certainly environment can nurture or destroy
it.
But I can tell you sadly that I’ve seen
writers come to screenwriting and really,
really want to get it.
But they don’t and you’ve tried every
different way.
I was speaking recently to a friend who is
a UCLA instructor who said “I’ve always
believed that anybody can be taught how to
write.
And then every once and awhile somebody walks
into my class that reminds me that…no!
It’s just not the case.”
There are some things that either you understand
them innately or you don’t.
I think most people that come to this come
with some innate understanding of screenwriting.
With the flow of screenwriting.
With the general structure, the general rhythm
of screenwriting.
But I think you certainly want an environment
that you nurture it, to promote it and to
help you rise to your very best.